que princess delos métro paris et thomas
nüssli bienne 6
la guitare est ouvert de combat libre
parisse latino qu'est ce que vous pensez
des transports en commun parisiens
madame parisien voilà j'ai pris le bus
pour venir de la gare de lyon et j'ai
trouvé super super pas de problème votre
soeur elle en pense quoi
pareil j'ai regardé ces trolls son
prénom je vis de lui dire il s'appelle
philippe un filou on t'embrasse je pars
avec elle on va semer chauvineau voit
les transports en commun parisiens
fonctionnent quand même plutôt bien vous
je dirais même très bien et votre est il
en pense quoi
combien va s'arrêter quoi et tout est
ouvert
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens très pratique et
très rapide est votre seul en pense quoi
pratique et rapide pour donner deux
heures non plus quoi on échange c'est
plutôt pratique ça sert pas mal prévu
que c'est assez bouché
ici ça nous aide pas mal surtout quand
c'est gratuit
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent ton frère
bien tu as vu ton soit la barca rigaux
c'est pourquoi la temps ça va bien venu
plus tard en plus je cherche le bon
cheval à moi je sais pas la balle
arrêtée ou mal alalalala n'était pas là
à traiter ou voilà